Game of Thrones fans can and will find plenty
of reasons to feel outraged over an episode's
embrace of darkness.
Viewers kicked, screamed, cried, and begged
for comfort after watching the "Rains of Castamere"
episode from season 3, better known as the
installment featuring the Red Wedding.
Audiences once again felt their stomachs churn
when Prince Oberyn Martell got his brains
bashed in during season 4's "The Mountain
and the Viper," and felt a similar feeling
of dread when Shireen Baratheon was burned
alive on the season 5 episode "The Dance of
Dragons."
While watching the third episode of season
8, titled "The Long Night," fans took to social
media to air their latest grievances about
the show.
Now, while the practice of criticizing on
Twitter is nothing new for the Game of Thrones
fandom, the April 28th episode elicited a
rather unique, highly specific complaint.
According to fans, the episode was just too
dark, in the most literal way.
Not long after “The Long Night” began,
Twitter exploded with complaints about how
dark the much-anticipated battle sequence
was.
For many, the episode was nearly unwatchable
because the lighting was so dim.
Variety writer Caroline Darya Framke tweeted
mid-episode:
"Sure we can't see anything on #GameofThrones
without squinting, but the thing is, it's
DARK at night and the ice dragon show is extremely
committed to realism."
News reporter Courtney Theriault had the perfect
response to the frustrating darkness, tweeting:
"After watching #BattleOfWinterfell, I honestly
don't know if I'll ever be able to look at
a sunny sky again without going blind."
One user posted an impassioned tweet asking
television executives to think of the audience
before deciding how to light each episode,
writing:
"Dear people making TV shows, THE VIEWERS
AT HOME WOULD PREFER IF THEY COULD SEE WHAT
WAS HAPPENING ON SCREEN STOP MAKING EVERYTHING
SO DARK.
Sincerely, Everyone watching tonight's #GameOfThrones."
Another Twitter user also expressed increasing
frustration over not being able to fully see
everything that was going down during the
Battle of Winterfell, tweeting:
"No clue what's happening in Game of Thrones
cause it's too dark.
I have adjusted the settings on my TV and
it still didn't help.
Guess I will be reading show summaries tomorrow
bright and early.”
Another fan took direct aim at HBO, slamming
the network for spending enormous amounts
of money on episodes where viewers have little
idea what’s unfolding due to how dark it
is:
"HBO: Let's make a show about dragons and
zombies and spend a gazillion dollars on it.
Also HBO: Let's make it so dark literally
no one can tell what's happening."
Fortunately, not every Game of Thrones fan
took issue with the lighting choice.
Many viewers started firing back on Twitter
at those bashing the episode, arguing that
no one should have been surprised by the lack
of light.
After all, the episode was literally titled
"The Long Night."
And as we know, nighttime has historically
been pretty dark:
"Game of Thrones has been visually dark since
day 1.
It's funny that people are upset now like
it's new.
I figured last night was shot the way that
it was to add to the chaos for the viewer.
The characters didn't know [what] was going
on and neither did we.”
Another user wrote:
"Stop barking that it was too dark!
You better buy some high quality TV or should
have watch it on HD you fools!
It was meant to be dark cinematography because
it happened during dark winter.
The characters also had a hard time seeing
so it was actually immersive."
ScreenRant features editor Hannah Shaw-Williams
had perhaps the most level-headed reaction
to the criticism.
According to her, those who found fault with
"The Long Night" for being incredibly dark
are entitled to their opinion, and those who
had no trouble making out everything that
happened shouldn't "shout down" those who
didn’t have the same experience.
The editor tweeted:
"... Like, do I need to get out the histograms
to prove how insanely under-lit this show
is?
I feel like this is some kind of weird mass
gas-lighting campaign.
Btw if you are gas-lighting, please send your
gas lights to HBO bc they clearly need them."
Overall, "The Long Night" was a pretty epic
episode despite some major events being difficult
to see.
Melisandre returned to Winterfell and ignited
the Dothraki's weapons with fire courtesy
of the Lord of Light, the dead rose in the
crypts of Winterfell, Theon Greyjoy heroically
sacrificed his life to try and defend Bran
Stark, a few major characters died during
battle, and Arya Stark went full Prince That
Was Promised by killing the Night King with
her dagger made of Valyrian steel.
After all… she knows the true secrets of
combat:
"Stick them with the pointy end."
At the end of the day, when you play the game
of thrones, you either win or you die.
And when you watch Game of Thrones, you either
invest in some night-vision goggles to see
what's happening or you strain your eyes trying.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.